tal cual se señalaba el resultado ha
sido sorprendente hay un voto que es
anti conservador y también anti derecha
que ha quedado en evidencia y que va a
obligar a distintos actores no solamente
a negociar y conversar sino aquí a
priorizar lo que más importante del país
a futuro en esa gracia sentido una
convención incluyente con paridad de
género para pueblo originario y con un
tiempo acotado para redactarla para el
que hacerse cargo no solamente de
interpretar el pasado sino que también
diseñar y dibujar el futuro
probablemente es ahí donde el diálogo
puede ser mucho más lucky pero y eso lo
que está representado hoy día y no
resultado las urnas donde finalmente los
partidos tradicionales han terminado con
una muy exigua representación y los
independientes han arrasado dentro de lo
que son los resultados de la
constituyente pero también en
gobernadores y también lo porque ha
pasado con alcaldes y concejales